[Musique]
je suis sûr qu'il y en a un par là en
tout cas l'année dernière il y en avait
un il est là et voilà tous mes oeufs
sont dans le même panier mais au fait
pourquoi mange-t-on des oeufs en
chocolat à pâques
allez dans l'atelier je vais vous
expliquer le coup du lapin en chocolat
bien sûr l'origine des oeufs de pâques
remonte sans doute à des milliers
d'années
l'oeuf représente en effet l'origine de
la vie ou la renaissance dans de
nombreuses civilisations chez les perses
les égyptiens ou encore les gaulois il
était donc coutumier d'offrir des oeufs
parfois décorés au moment du printemps
quand la nature renaît
regardez ce qu'on m'a offert joliment
décorées non cette tradition printanière
est aussi celle de la pac dans la
religion chrétienne les premiers
chrétiens se serait en effet offert des
oeufs à pâques pour symboliser la
résurrection du christ eh oui finalement
il est sorti de sa tombe
comme la vie sort de la pluie à partir
du moyen-âge la tradition serait devenu
encore plus forte à cause du carême
vous savez cette période de jeûne avant
pâques pendant laquelle il était
interdit de consommer de la viande des
oeufs au lieu de les jeter il était vide
et décoré et offert le dimanche de
pâques et les cloches dans tout ça j'y
viens en france comme les cloches des
églises sont condamnés au silence en
signe de deuil entre le jeudi saint et
le dimanche de pâques les adultes aurait
inventé une histoire pour faire rêver
les enfants
les cloches des églises partirait le
jeudi à rome pour se faire bénir par le
pape et déposeraient leurs oeufs
en revenant le dimanche chez nos voisins
d'outre-rhin en allemagne c'est le lapin
ou le lièvre les symboles païen de la
fertilité qui se chargent de cacher les
oeufs dans le jardin
ce n'est cependant qu'à partir de la
seconde moitié du 19e
un clair que les chocolats qui ont eu
l'idée de proposer des oeufs de pâques
entièrement en chocolat et
progressivement de lapins des poules et
tout un tas d'autres friandises
chocolatées
c'est bon mais comment fabrique-t-on du
chocolat à l'est direction la cuisine on
va voir ça sur la planche pour faire du
chocolat il faut d'abord récolter les
fruits d'un arbre tropical le cacao y
il donne des cabosses comme celle ci à
l'intérieur se cachent des graines
on parle de fèves de cacao une cabosse
peut-on contenir une soixantaine on a
dans la caboche toi une fois récupéré
les fèves qui au départ sont enrobées de
pulpe sont mis à fermenter pendant
quelques jours puis séchés au soleil
pendant deux semaines vient alors
l'étape de la torréfaction les fèves
sont chauffés jusqu'à 130 degrés environ
une demi heure il ne reste plus alors
qu'à les broyer pour obtenir une pâte de
cacao
cette pâte est ensuite pressés aussi
étrange que cela puisse paraître on en
extrait du beurre de cacao puis la
partie sèche
débarrassé de son beurre que l'on dit
maintenant maigre cette partie sèche et
broyés et on obtient de la poudre aux
cette amère enfin ta mère je parle de
l'amertume et c'est à ce stade que la
fabrication du chocolat tel qu on le
déguste peut réellement commencé pour
faire du chocolat noir on mélange du
sucre et du cacao maigre on malaxe
pendant plusieurs heures en ajoutant au
fur et à mesure du beurre de cacao c'est
ce qu'on appelle le conchage dans le
jargon des chocolatiers durant cette
étape chaque particule chocolatées sans
robe d'un film
ce qui permet d'obtenir un chocolat
onctueux effondre quand il sort des
malaxeurs le mélange avoisine 75 degrés
il faut le refroidir en plusieurs étapes
c'est indispensable pour que le chocolat
deviennent brillant écran corps tout en
restant de fondants c'est ce que les
spécialistes appellent le tempérage bas
nylon faut être patient je commence à
broyer du noir - pas vous et je n'ai pas
encore tout dit à propos du chocolat
noir justement plus il ya de pâte de
cacao cacao maigre et beurre de cacao
plus le pourcentage est élevée c'est
écrit sur la tablette 70 % pour celui ci
pour faire du chocolat au lait
maintenant on prend les mêmes
ingrédients et on ajoute du lait est
bonne pour le chocolat blanc
c'est encore différent ce n'est pas
vraiment du chocolat il ne contient pas
de pâte de cacao seulement du beurre de
cacao du sucre et du lait en poudre
moi j'adore le chocolat noir et vous
lequel préférez vous dites le moi en
commentaire ça me fera plaisir personne
me parle à moi y pour l'autre quoi qu'il
en soit savez-vous qu'à l'origine le
chocolat est en fait une boisson et même
d'après certains scientifiques une
boisson alcoolisée
je vous explique le cacao est originaire
d'amérique centrale les archéologues
américains en ont retrouvé des traces au
honduras dans de la vaisselle vieille de
plus de trois mille ans à l'époque
cette boisson était obtenue grâce à la
fermentation de la pulpe qui entoure la
fève de cacao et les mayas et les
aztèques ont ensuite eu l'idée
d'utiliser la fève de cacao tout entière
en la faisant sécher et griller puis en
les broyant vous connaissez la recette
afin d'obtenir une pâte qu'il mélangeait
avec de l'eau pour préparer une boisson
nommé socrates
c'est de ce terme que viendrait le mot
espagnol chocolatées puis chocolat aux
français quand les européens débarque en
amérique à la fin du xvème siècle il
ignore tout du cacao et de cette boisson
il ignore aussi qu'elle sert de monnaie
à l'époque
l'histoire raconte même que des
marchands maya aurait offert des fèves
de cacao à christophe colomb qui n'y
aurait absolument pas prêté attention
raconte même qu'il les aurait confondu
avec des crottes de chèvre vous vous
rendez compte
à cause de lui l'histoire du chocolat
aurait pu être étouffée dans l'oeuf au
16e siècle
hernán cortés rapporte la boisson en
espagne où elle fait fureur dans sa
version européenne on y ajoute du sucre
du lait et de la vanille pour adoucir
sur l'amertume
le breuvage gagne ensuite la france
grâce à marie thérèse d'autriche la
forme d'espagne qui épouse louis xiv
accro au chocolat
elle rapporte dans ses valises bien
évidemment ce qui se fait à la cour
devient vite une mode et le chocolat
conquiert à l'aristocratie française
depuis il s'est considérablement
démocratisé tablette pâte à tartiner
confiserie chocolat en poudre en france
nous consommons chaque année 325 mille
tonnes de chocolat dont 15000 en
chocolat de pâques
ça en fait des lapins et des poules
c'est beau et en plus ça fait du bien
mais pas étonnant ce chocolat contient
70 % de cacao et de chocolat noir est
bon pour la santé
le cacao est riche en flavonoïdes des
substances aux multiples bienfaits qui
font baisser la tension artérielle
protège le coeur et les artères aide à
lutter contre le déclin cognitif le
cacao protégerait aussi le foie et enfin
il serait bon pour le moral grâce au
magnésium qu'il contient mais aussi
parce qu'il favorise la sécrétion
d'endorphines et messagers du bonheur et
de la détente dans notre cerveau mans
lors l'oeuf ou la poule
quoiqu'une petites oreilles de lapin en
attendant de savoir qui je vais croquer
rendez vous sur le compte instagram ou
la page facebook epicure yeux pour
tenter de gagner à délicieux coffrets de
chocolats pour pâques donnait à
l'intérieur il y a même une tablette de
chocolat personnalisés epicure yeux je
suis sûr que vous allez adorer le goût
du savoir si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]